in addition to being lost crypto can be
stolen
crypto is typically stolen in one of
three ways
many people hold their crypto at a place
called an exchange that makes it easier
with which to transact with crypto to
buy the crypto transfer the crypto or
sell the crypto
sometimes exchanges are hacked
professionals will figure out the codes
we'll get into the exchange and steal
the money from the exchange that's a
little bit like robbing a bank
the most important and largest example
we have of that kind of a crypto heist
today that we know of publicly is that a
place called mount gox happened a few
years ago it could happen again
the second way that crypto gets stolen
is people have accounts at these
exchanges
the way you log into the account is
typically password based
if somebody steals your password it's a
little bit like they're getting your
credentials at a bank
they can then go to the exchange
they pretend to be you and they transfer
the crypto that sits in your account
from your account at the exchange to
their account probably in the ukraine or
korea or who knows
now the exchanges will legitimately say
that they have not been hacked
they haven't
it's your account at the exchange that's
been hacked
third if you don't trust the exchanges
and if instead you keep your code on
your own
that code can be stolen too
piece of paper can be taken if you've
got the code on a thumb drive the thumb
drive can be stolen if you've got the
code on a hard drive of a computer the
computer can be stolen as well
now here's what's interesting
because once the transfer happens
from your account to that third account
which may be in the ukraine korea
who knows where
it's not coming back
these exchanges are immutable
they're recorded and as a practical
matter most people not all people most
people don't know the destination of
where the money or the crypto has gone
from their account
so as a practical matter
if your crypto is lost
or if your crypto is stolen
you can't go to court
you can't say this person stole it from
me there is no recourse and this raises
a very interesting and somewhat ironic
observation
at a certain level a large motivation
for the creation of much of this crypto
economy is distrust in the state
we don't want to have the central bank
issue the currency
we don't trust the government we want to
create a system of finance that is extra
territorial in a certain sense
well okay
if we have a system that's extra
territorial and exists outside
of the government
then the government isn't going to be
able to help you
if the value that you have is lost or
stolen
it's part of the bargain you make here